♪ ♪
>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR ARE
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE
EXPOSE THE BIG CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
THE IMPEACHMENT BATTLE PLUS
"SNL" AND A LEGENDARY ACTOR GO
ALL IN FOR PUSHING THE PRESIDENT
OUT.
JOINING US WITH ALL THE DETAILS,
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND ALL THE
IMPEACHMENT DRAMA.
IT IS DRAMA IN THREE ACTS.
HE SAW SOMETHING ELSE TODAY THAT
COULD AFFECT THE OUTCOME.
>> YOU KNOW I ALWAYS LOOK FOR
THE POP CULTURE PLAY.
HOW THIS IS BEING RECEIVED BY
EVERYDAY AMERICANS, SO I WANTED
TO COMPARE THE STYLE, NOT THE
SUBSTANCE, OF ONE NANCY PELOSI
AND THE PRESIDENT SAID TODAY.
SPEAKER SEVEN STARTED BY NOTING
THE
HISTORY OF THIS DAY.
>> WE ARE HERE ON THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF WHEN
JAMAL KHASHOGGI WAS KILLED.
A VERY SAD THING.
>> THIS IMPEACHMENT BATTLE IS
FIRST AND FOREMOST A POLITICAL
BATTLE.
IN BETWEEN LOST WORDS, PUTIN
THOUGHT TO ALIGN HER BOSS WITH
THAT OF THE FOREFATHERS.
>> NOT THAT WE PLACE OURSELVES
IN THE CATEGORY OF GREATNESS OF
OUR FOUNDERS, BUT WE DO PLACE
OURSELVES IN A TIME OF URGENCY
ON THE THREAT TO OUR
CONSTITUTION AND THE SYSTEM OF
CHECKS AND BALANCES THAT IS
BEING MADE.
>> IT'S WANDERING, IT'S
UNFOCUSED.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW AMERICANS
ARE RECEIVING THIS.
SHE IS NOT HELPING HER CAUSE.
EVEN IF SHE HAD A GREAT
ARGUMENT.
>> Laura: DO WE REALLY THINK
SHE IS SITTING AROUND READING
FEDERALIST 18?
I MEAN, SHE IS NOT DOING ANY OF
THAT.
>> WHAT ABOUT WHEN SHE PAUSED,
THINKING ABOUT THE HORRIFIC
MURDER OF JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
THAT WAS ODD.
THAT WAS A WEIRD TURN.
ALL RIGHT, HERE'S THE PRESIDENT
FROM THE OVAL OFFICE TODAY.
[REPORTER QUESTION]
>> WHEN IT WHISTLE-BLOWER --
OKAY, ARE YOU READY?
I HEARD THE WHISTLE-BLOWERS
REPORT PEER TO THIS COUNTRY HAS
TO FIND OUT WHO THAT PERSON WAS
BECAUSE THAT PERSON IS A SPY INM
BECAUSE THAT PERSON IS A SPY INY
OPINION.
ARE YOU READY?
>> I HAVE TO NOTE SOMETHING HER
HERE.
HE IS ALL IN THIS THING AND HE
USES THE TACTIC AND I'VE WATCHED
IT REPEATEDLY WHERE HE GOES,
"YOU READY?"
AND THEN HE DROPS THE LINE.
>> Laura: HE MAKES YOU STOP.
>> ARE YOU READY?
IT'S A TACTIC.
WATCH THE CONTRAST AND
COMMUNICATIONS HERE.
>> IT'S VERY SAD, I DON'T SEE
IMPEACHMENT AS A UNIFYING THING
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SENSE OF
MISSION THAT HE DID WHAT HE DID.
>> HE DID WHAT HE DID, WHAT DID
HE DO?
AND IT'S SAD.
>> Laura: HE DID WHAT HE DID,
IT'S UNIFYING, IT'S NOT
UNIFYING.
>> WATCH HOW TRUMP CHANNELS
PASSION FOR MAXIMUM EFFECT.
>> BIDEN AND HIS SON ARE STONE
COLD CRICKET, AND YOU KNOW IT.
HIS SON WALKS OUT WITH MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, THE KID KNOWS
NOTHING.
YOU KNOW IT AND SO DO WE.
>> HE HAD THE SAME APPROACH IN
THE OVAL OFFICE.
HE'S EMPHATIC, HE'S INDIGNANT.
IT MATTERS TO HIM.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE IS IN THE GAME.
PELOSI LOOKS LIKE SHE IS TRYING
TO CONVINCE THE FACULTY LOUNGE
TO ADD A SMOKE WORM.
[LAUGHS]
NOW THE POP-CULTURE SHAPES THE
OPINIONS OF MANY AMERICANS WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE HOT POLITICAL
TOPICS.
THIS WEEK "SNL" OPENED THEIR
45TH SEASON WITH A DESPERATE
PRESIDENT FACING IMPEACHMENT.
WATCH.
>> GIVE ME RUDY GIULIANI ON THE
PHONE.
>> MR. TRUMP, WHAT'S NEW?
>> WHAT YOU MEAN WHAT'S NEW?
I'M BEING IMPEACHED.
GOT ANOTHER CALL.
OKAY.
WHO'S THIS?
>> IT'S ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR.
STAY CALM, MR. PRESIDENT.
I KNOW THINGS LOOK BAD RIGHT NOW
BUT I'VE GOT OUR TOP GUY ON
THIS.
>> GOOD.
LET'S GET HIM ON THE PHONE, TOO.
>> HELLO!
>> NONE OF THIS IS WORKING.
AND THE RATINGS HAVE PROVEN.
30% DROP --
>> Laura: RAYMOND IS A REALLY
GOOD IMPRESSIONIST AND YOU CAN
DO A GREAT RUDY GIULIANI.
THAT WAS A BOMB FROM BEGINNING
TO END.
>> LAURA, WE ARE, WE ARE SUING
EVERYONE.
WE WANT EVERYBODY OUT --
>> Laura: "SNL" HAS GOT TO GET
RAYMOND!
>> INCLUDING YOU, LAURA.
IN THE HOOP EARRINGS.
>> Laura: RAMAGE IS NEVER
GOING TO COME ON AGAIN.
OUR OLD PAL BOB DE NIRO TOOK AIM
AT US OVER THE PAST WEEKEND.
YOU'RE GOING TO REMEMBER WE TOOK
HIM ON FOR CURSING OUT THE
PRESIDENT AT THE TONY AWARDS BUT
EVEN BEFORE THAT IN JANUARY OF
2018.
>> THIS [BLEEP] 88 IS THE
PRESIDENT.
THE GUY IS A [BLEEP] FOOL.
>> HE IS JUST OFF THE RAILS.
>> HE IS ONE OF THE GREAT ACTORS
OF THE GENERATION BUT IT
UNDERMINES WHEN YOU ENGAGE IN
THIS AD HOMINEM.
>> HE WENT ON THE AIR TO RESPOND
US.
>> WHEN YOU SAY THAT FOLKS ON
FOX MAFFEI APPEARED AT THE
DUMMIES YOU GOT UP THERE AND
CURSED.
[BLEEP].
SPEAK THIS
GUY IS LIKE A GANGSTER.
HE COMES ALONG AND HAS SAID AND
DONE THINGS.
THIS IS TERRIBLE.
THIS GUY IS CRAZY.
WE'VE GOT TO GET HIM OUT.
>> Laura: JUST BECAUSE HE
PLAYED A GANGSTER DOESN'T MEAN
THAT HE KNOWS WHAT A GANGSTER I
IS.
SPEAK OF THE COLLAPSE INTO
PROFANITIES AND HAVE LITTLE
INSIGHT HERE.
THIS WAS ONCE A GREAT ACTOR.
HE IS PUSHING THIS MOVIE, "THE
IRISHMAN" WHICH SHOULD BE CALLED
"THE AIRBRUSH MAN" BECAUSE THEY
ARE WALKING HIS AGE BACK WITH A
CGI.
THIS IS CHEAP AND LOW AND IT'S
BEEN EIGHT ROBERT DE NIRO.
>> Laura: WHY DO I ALWAYS
THINK HE IS DUSTIN HOFFMAN?
AL PACINO, ROBERT DE NIRO,